I want to use this video
to kind of make sure we
intuitively and otherwise and
understand the difference
between a Z-statistic--
something I have trouble
saying-- and a T-statistic.
So in a lot of what we're doing
in this inferential
statistics, we're trying to
figure out what is the
probability of getting a
certain sample mean.
So what we've been doing,
especially when we have a
large sample size-- so let
me just draw a sampling
distribution here.
So let's say we have a sampling
distribution of the
sample mean right here.
It has some assumed mean value
and some standard deviation.
What we want to do is any result
that we get, let's say
we get some sample
mean out here.
We want to figure out the
probability of getting a
result at least as
extreme as this.
So you can either figure out the
probability of getting a
result below this and subtracted
that from 1, or
just figure out this area
right over there.
And to do that we've been
figuring out how many standard
deviations above the mean
we actually are.
The way we figured that out is
we take our sample mean, we
subtract from that our mean
itself, we subtract from that
what we assume the mean should
be, or maybe we don't know
what this is.
And then we divide that by the
standard deviation of the
sampling distribution.
This is how many standard
deviations we
are above the mean.
That is that distance
right over there.
Now, we usually don't know
what this is either.
We normally don't know
what that is either.
And the central limit theorem
told us that assuming that we
have a sufficient sample size,
this thing right here, this
thing is going to be the same
thing as-- the sample is going
to be the same thing as the
standard deviation of our
population divided by
the square root
of our sample size.
So this thing right over here
can be re-written as our
sample mean minus the mean of
our sampling distribution of
the sample mean divided by
this thing right here--
divided by our population mean,
divided by the square
root of our sample size.
And this is essentially our
best sense of how many
standard deviations away from
the actual mean we are.
And this thing right here, we've
learned it before, is a
Z-score, or when we're dealing
with an actual statistic when
it's derived from the sample
mean statistic, we call this a
Z-statistic.
And then we could look it up
in a Z-table or in a normal
distribution table to say what's
the probability of
getting a value of this
Z or greater.
So that would give us
that probability.
So what's the probability
of getting that
extreme of a result?
Now normally when we've done
this in the last few videos,
we also do not know what the
standard deviation of the
population is.
So in order to approximate that
we say that the Z-score
is approximately, or the
Z-statistic, is approximately
going to be-- so let me just
write the numerator over
again-- over, we estimate this
using our sample standard
deviation-- let me do this in
a new color-- with using our
sample standard deviation.
And this is OK if our sample
size is greater than 30.
Or another way to think about
it is this will be normally
distributed if our sample
size is greater than 30.
Even this approximation will
be approximately normally
distributed.
Now, if your sample size is less
than 30, especially if
it's a good bit less than
30, all of a sudden this
expression will not be
normally distributed.
So let me re-write the
expression over here.
Sample mean minus the mean of
your sampling distribution of
the sample mean divided by your
sample standard deviation
over the square root of
your sample size.
We just said if this thing is
well over 30, or at least 30,
then this value right here, this
statistic, is going to be
normally distributed.
If it's not, if this is small,
then this is going to have a
T-distribution.
And then you're going to do the
exact same thing you did
here, but now you would assume
that the bell is no longer a
normal distribution, so this
example it was normal.
All of Z's are normally
distributed.
Over here in a T-distribution,
and this will actually be a
normalized T-distribution
right here because we
subtracted out the mean.
So in a normalized
T-distribution, you're going
to have a mean of 0.
And what you're going to do is
you want to figure out the
probability of getting a T-value
at least this extreme.
So this is your T-value you
would get, and then you
essentially figure out the area
under the curve right
over there.
So a very easy rule of thumb
is calculate this quantity
either way.
Calculate this quantity
If you will have more than 30
samples, if your sample size
is more than 30, your sample
standard deviation is going to
be a good approximator for your
population standard deviation.
And so this whole thing is
going to be approximately
normally distributed, and so
you can use a Z-table to
figure out the probability
of getting a result
at least that extreme.
If your sample size is small,
then this statistic, this
quantity, is going to have a
T-distribution, and then
you're going to have to use a
T-table to figure out the
probability of getting a T-value
at least this extreme.
And we're going to see this
in an example a couple
of videos from now.
Anyway, hopefully that helped
clarify some things in your
head about when to use a
Z-statistic or when to use a
T-statistic.